I have the pleasure to introduce two of
our own students undergrad eToro attack
attack BA and graduated in Sergio Iran
can too
they were guided in a reflection on the
life and legacy of dr. King we hear
first from it our and then followed by
Sergio
good morning everyone my name is eToro
attack ba I'm a junior here I'm studying
mechanical engineering with a
concentration in product development and
as Lulu said I'm your undergraduate
speaker for this program also I want to
thank you all for coming out before I
jump right into the seat so thank you
all for being here I'm really honored to
present to you all today it's been three
years since I sat in my makeshift study
and press submit on the series of
documents that were supposed to somehow
represent my character my ambitions and
my potential I was 16 and I had labored
for hours
stamping permanently onto a page
intentions and goals that today I have
not met because my expectations for what
I would grow to consider to be my
crowning achievements at MIT
could have been based in no sense of
reality because I in reality didn't know
what MIT was MIT is the mecca of
innovation and technology yes the
absolute greatest place in the world to
receive an engineering education yes a
space to conduct advanced research and
meat genius professors and students yes
but when I take a moment to consider
what has really shaped my experience and
been monumento and my growth here it
hasn't been the revving arms of robots
which don't get me wrong I do love but
the warm arms of the community I've
built over these two and a half years
I've been constantly switching out and
reorganizing the pieces that construct
my image of MIT and I want to show you
all that this is not just an institute
but a place to grow in your morals and
your leadership wide-eyed and anxious in
the classic freshman way in the fall of
2013 I did in a manner of speaking
something that could stop almost anyone
in their tracks
I met MIT students yes indeed the most
profound moments in my experience here
have been the conversations that I had
not with professors or advisers but with
the fresh-faced twenty year olds who I
happened to run into in the dining hall
before the
chalk Dustin 630 study sessions the
young men and women who wore their
pajama pants because they were that
comfortable with me sharing experiences
that completely floored me and left me
grappling for a way to take action I
have although not been able to fulfill
every eager promise on my application
had the opportunity to do something
remarkable I've been able to listen to
my peers tell me about their deepest
insecurities their qualms with the
Institute I remember one day about a
year and a half ago wanting to tell my
close friends who had been called the
n-word and told that they don't belong
here something to the effect of that
couldn't have happened at MIT but it did
and things just like it have happened
again and again I've heard my Speer
speak up speak about feeling unwelcome
on their own campus afraid to speak up
in class their fear of getting the
answer wrong and thus perpetuating
stereotypes about and feeling
invalidated in regards to how race and
gender have edged persistent obstacles
into their experiences told to let it go
and move on about having been told
throughout their lives that they aren't
supposed to be smart and subsequently
not forming a relationship or fearing
their own intellect about being told
that they don't look like they go to MIT
or realizing that MIT makes them no
different from the men and women who
have been victims of profiling and
police violence about feeling abandoned
unfit underrepresented and without key
resources so many times we've laughed
helplessly and held hands asking each
other rhetorically how we can possibly
achieve complete academic focus when
faced with so many problems beyond just
the ones on our piece odds MIT is not
just an institute because it hasn't just
given me an education in the traditional
sense MIT introduced me to the people
who have infected me with their passion
for building a stronger community and a
more inclusive society and inspired me
to acquire positions within the black
Students Union in the black woman's
alliance in order to work towards
bettering campus life opportunity and
our understanding of each other
unfortunately because I have held these
positions I can say in a personal
connected sort of way
that in this past year in particular we
have truly improved our level of
discussion as a community on race
although we have certainly spoken in
some capacity about diversity and
equality in the past we've been more
deliberate in engaging the variety of
sub communities and power levels than at
any other time since I've been here
we as undergrads have been able to
compose a strong list of recommendations
we as faculty staff administrators and
students have been able to form a
sisterhood and share our stories through
my sisters keeper we as a community have
been able to maintain a dialogue through
ask a black person and other organized
discussions that level of impact makes
me extremely proud of the MIT community
especially my peers who have stepped up
and had the courage to spearhead many of
these efforts and to get so many other
people on board it is for this reason
that I can say to my MIT to my peers in
the MIT community one thing that I know
without a doubt about them you are a
contagion you are everything they say
you are in the books and the movies your
words have this power to hold like a
glue on the mind that takes them in and
then compel that mind to take them it to
share them and spread them and this is a
power that like all comes with great
responsibility I challenge you to infect
others with your voice the voices in
your head don't have to be a silent and
personal affliction they should be an
epidemic on the grounds of our campus
because you are the revolutionary you
are the difference and I know from
experience that once someone catches
wind of your emotion and listens to your
thoughts and ideas the virus of your
voice is chronic and incurable the
greatest recent example of this is the
aforementioned list of recommendations
which has now received backing from the
Academic Council the list was made
possible largely because we have been
able to speak amongst ourselves
consistently to the point where we all
through our own or through others
experiences have this mutual knowing of
what our challenges are here at MIT we
all can say in one United voice that we
need representation in mental health and
that we need faculty that truly values
the well-being of the students
and that we need diversification of our
departments and that we must teach our
students at least some basic knowledge
about the institutions of racism and how
they are harmful to the growth of our
society thus as an undergrad who is in
some sense at least representing some of
us here today I want to invite you all
to our table and what I mean by that is
I want us to further this trend of the
kind of conversation that made the list
of recommendations possible I want us as
the entire MIT community to be
deliberate in taking our discussion
about diversity down from the emails to
the types of everyday conversations that
we don't have to suit up for or be
careful about the kind that my peers and
I have at the dinner table in McCormick
or the tables in the house to kitchen or
the big round table in the BSU lounge
where we don't have to navigate so
carefully that we missed some key points
or sentiments every day conversation
especially when it transcends the
boundaries of faculty staff student
administrator has the power to lend you
an enormous amount of perspective and a
mouth it's completely unparalleled by
anything with a header and the
salutation here at MIT we lead in
innovation we lead in research we lead
in the financial and career success of
our graduates and now it is time for us
to lead in action to set an example for
our peer institutions on how to conduct
community-wide diversity and inclusion
efforts as MLK once said the function of
education is to teach one to think
intensively and critically intelligence
plus character that is the goal of true
education we cannot allow the Institute
to exist without without making a
deliberate effort to develop this kind
of character to encourage the
facilitation of the conversations that
we continually avoid on account of
discomfort if we truly want continued
progress we have to learn that we are
not at the mercy of discomfort we are
not at the mercy of discomfort and we
must learn to overcome it we must learn
how to
directly into someone's eyes when we
stay or listen to something like people
don't feel wanted here we have to
explain and hold accountable we have to
learn how to listen to others
misunderstanding of our of our
sentiments without shutting down because
in my case for instance growing up in a
Nigerian household and going to a subpar
public Georgia Georgia high school and
having separated parents and having some
relatives who went to MIT before me and
some who never made it out of the
village all of these things matter but
we have to be proactive and helping each
other to understand why they matter this
is the only way to identify and address
the resources that are missing here I
say to my peers speak speak about what
can be done better speak about how
community life can be improved speak and
others will follow suit because you are
a contagion infect with your voice and
not every idea will be gold but every
idea has validity and power we must all
speak because we've still got a long way
to go here at MIT thank you